speaking of endurance and suffering
what have you learned from lex friedman
since you've been friends with him the
guy works a lot you can text him or call
him at pretty much any hour except um
the early morning hours that he happens
to be in because he's likely to be
asleep you know lexus is a really
interesting one um
because
you know like a lot of scientists and
engineers yet he has that ability to
really drop into the trench which is
certainly not unique to scientists and
engineers but is really helpful
i think
lex comes at things from a from at once
a very engineering physics perspective
which you know obviously computer
science robots and all ai and all that
he loves that stuff but you know there's
a phrase that he's used over and over
again in our conversations and he's
talked about this publicly that i've
started to pay a bit more attention to
because he says it so many times which
is you know approach life with love in
your heart
you know which is weird right you think
about an engineer who's thinking like
this goes there and this is what's going
to predict the best outcome and anything
like approach things with love in your
heart and i think he's right
because and i think that is very
powerful because
there are so many pitfalls
and by pitfalls what i mean are energy
sinks that you know across the day from
the time you wake up until you go to
sleep at night there's so many places
for you to put your energy can go into
online battles it can go into
uh you know texting five different
people it can be investing in one person
it can be there's so many things and so
much of success in any domain is about
yes maintaining focus we hear about that
a lot focus focus focus but what is
focus focus is really about not allowing
energy to dissipate into these kind of
meaningless trails so i think about lex
and i as i do for all people i think you
know what animal does he best represent
or what animal best represents him i i
think of all people like this i have
this kind of weird process where after i
spend some time with somebody it just
pops to mind like i can't tell you what
animal comes to mind yet you might see
that after the ice bath later on you'll
see how long it is you might be you
might be a polar bear um super
comfortable in the water um the cold
water but i think that you know at some
point i realized that that lexus gets
very fixated on things
very very fixated but he also knows how
to disengage
and he really avoids energy sinks
through this and losses through this
kind of love thing that he's really into
um because anger is very energetically
demanding it's great fuel but it's not
efficient fuel overall right it's like
having a gas tank full of fuel but there
are a lot of leaks in it whereas i do
think that doing things out of genuine
desire there's a calm
sort of energized balance that comes
with that and you feel like you can go
forever so this is starting to sound a
little bit woo it sounds like oh you
know the heart is more powerful than the
adrenals and like they're both powerful
the adrenals can keep you alive and
enduring for a long long time but if you
do things out of anger and friction for
too long your immune system will crash
we know this
but it is
essentially infinite how much energy you
can derive out of genuine desire
to engage with something or somebody
well anonymously then
you know lex well his hair makes me
think some spiky thing he's sort of like
he's some he sort of has the like the
persistence of the porcupine but he has
he's definitely has i think he as much
as i don't want to admit it because i
wish it were me and not him but i think
the animal that best captures lex
because he's also a bit of a loner is
the wolverine i've spent a lot of time
thinking about actual wolverines not the
hugh jackman version of wolverines but
the actual wolverines they're very solo
animals unless they pair up to mate they
are incredibly strong he is freakishly
strong i've done jiu jitsu with him i'm
not good at jiu jitsu he is he's a black
belt jiu jitsu but he is freakishly
strong so if i had to pick an animal i'd
say probably um the wolverine what's
interesting about him i went to
thanksgiving with him last year which
was my first time of enjoying that
holiday here which is a fantastic
holiday i actually think we don't have
something in the uk where people sit
back and do that gratitude reflection
period
except for christmas you know people do
that end of year review but i really
think and especially the time of year
it's in it's perfect so
we were talking and
he was talking about the fact that he
was working hard but he feels this gap
between where he is and where he could
be which i i sounds like sense is a
common uh pattern yeah and
he was saying that a lot of the friends
that he speaks to will say you know
you're doing well you're working hard
and
he looked me in the eyes and he's like i
don't want them to say that i want them
to tell me to suck it up i want them to
tell me that i need to stop being such a
[ __ ] and keep going i was like it takes
an unbelievably singular person to work
as hard as he does i don't think that
the internet
whatever people know about how hard he
works
is only a small sliver of just how
obsessive and and committed he is and
for him to say that he wants to be
around more people that push him in that
way it made me realize that
perhaps uh i could be offering more to
my friends as well that offering them
just sort of
support
in the form of acceptance and and
presence and i'm hearing you and dude
you're doing great or whatever
reassurance in that way maybe isn't
always the best way to go about things
so yeah that was it's just something
that stuck in my mind it's something
it's a little model that i've kept with
me where i'm thinking look does my
friend need me to tell him that he's
doing good or does he need me to tell
him to suck it up and get his nose down
because i know that he can do it sounds
very much like lex and i'm learning
about your your internal workings a bit
too there are three kinds of reward two
of them are often discussed one is
rarely discussed but is pretty powerful
and i think it's useful to think about
toggling between these different rewards
whether or not for ourselves or whether
or not in trying to
stimulate and motivate other people
one of course is reward you did great
congratulations that was awesome loved
that podcast great that you got an a
plus on your report card or b-plus
because last year you got a c whatever
it is reward
then there's punishment right
this is obvious you screwed up like
you take something away or you take the
anticipation of reward away whatever it
is you screwed up you're punished you're
grounded etc you're not watching tv for
a month or whatever it is no screens for
a month then there's the third kind of
reward which is the reward that you hang
out in front of somebody
at a distance like a carrot on a stick
out in front of them which is not reward
for what they've accomplished but reward
that they can anticipate if they
accomplish something i think this could
be
very effective in the context that we're
talking about it which is how would i do
this with lex i'd say you know i really
loved this particular interview
if only the next time you have that
person on you also ask them this right
that's not a punishment you're not
saying it sucked because it didn't
include this you're not saying it wasn't
great you're saying
if next time you were to do that
i think it would be even better so
you're hanging a potential reward out in
front and i think that can be a very
powerful motivator so you can you know
we could build up a number of different
examples around this but this is not
often talked about in sort of reward
punishment schedules and motivation we
always think reward and punishment but
we think immediate reward immediate
punishment
now in terms of building habits
and goal setting and goal seeking we
know
that visualizing failure is
for better for worse is a far better
motivator than visualizing success if
you want to get people motivated to
start
right
to start now getting people to continue
involves regular rewards for reaching
milestones however and i should have
said this earlier
i want to make sure that we do emphasize
that the best schedule really is random
intermittent reinforcement so if you're
setting milestones on this run or in
your intellectual pursuits or business
pursuits or relationship pursuits
if you set a milestone and you get there
you do want to have a little bit of an
internal celebration remember it's all
internal so internal celebration not
extrinsic celebration
and reward
but every once in a while it's good to
just not reward yourself now at what
ratio should you do that well the the
computer modeling data say that the
optimal ratio of success successful
trials and uh unsuccessful trials for
learning and motivation is going to be
about 85 percent of the time to reward
yourself
and about 15 of the time to not reward
yourself so random intermittent lack of
reward is another way to think about it
and i talked about this with jocko a
little bit and he thought oh yeah
probably what we should do is have
workouts where it's a big fishbowl full
of ping pong balls and about 15 of them
are marked with reward but the other
ones is you do something and you get to
go take a ping pong ball out and if you
take that out then you get some reward
if it's marked and if it's not then you
don't and rather than every time you
accomplish something you go reward
yourself so here we're talking we're
getting kind of into the weeds of reward
schedules but i think if you really want
to support a friend punishment you
should use very judiciously although if
they really screw up a good friend as
they say will put um the friendship
ahead of the friend or the friend ahead
of the friendship excuse me um the
friend had like you're gonna tell them
what they really need to hear even if it
compromises the friendship if you really
believe they need to hear that
other times reward like that was awesome
congratulations
and then
occasionally if it's warranted
that was great ish
but it would be so much better if the
next time you did this or that was great
but you know honestly i think it was a
mixture of good and not so good so i
think those are three powerful ways to
reward and they can be mixed up and
toggled back and forth according to
whatever schedule allows that person to
continue what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you